[Music]
with ariana grande yeah everybody is
still talking about her engagement you
SNL star Pete Davidson but before they
found each other they were seriously
evolved with other people that's Pete
with his ex Cassy David the daughter of
comedian Larry David does he have dad's
approval
yeah hundreds of seven dating on and off
for two years he did SNL skits with her
dad and even got her face tattooed on
his right arm
just one day after announcing their
breakup last month he got that tattoo
covered up and days later went public
with now fiance Ariana getting her
initials inked on his body sharing
something emotional with somebody while
also doing what you love is such a
special thing Ariana and her ex rapper
Mac Miller also just broke it off last
month while he comforted Grande after
the bombing at her Manchester England
concert last spring by last fall it
looked as if Pete could have been
sending Ariana a secret message on SNL
by wearing her signature bunny mask
a source tells TT in relationships he is
the full steam ahead guy and that
Arianna went into this relationship at
full throttle our source fears her
sudden engagement after a bad breakup is
more about a sense of euphoria of and
true love
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]